bonjour bienvenue dans cette leçon avec
jean baptiste bonjour d'actifs bonjour
stéphane alors aujourd'hui on va du côté
de la grande-bretagne puisqu'on va
falloir les ouvertures écossaise
l'ouverture écossaise voilà ouverture
qui s'appelle comme ça pour des raisons
qui sont encore assez floues d'ailleurs
tous française cette ouverture c'est
qu'elle est très anciennes comme
beaucoup d'artistes sur 4,5 et qu'elle a
été remise au goût du jour par garry
kasparov
dans les années 90 il aujourd'hui encore
lui voilà il a joué tout sur 400 spagnol
zouine italienne il a joué l'écossaise
les spécialistes actuels sont un peu
plus rare maintenant il ya le joueur
russe roublev ski qui joue sa très
souvent avec de très bons résultats
l'écossaise c
un esprit particulier
c'est une ouverture tu positionnelle
vraiment les concepts sont très pointus
on va en parler dès qu'on jouera les
premiers coups mais c'est on va plutôt
parler en termes de structure de pions
au niveau de l'écossaise d'accord donc
on va voir cette ouverture sur 4,5
écossaise avec donc des concepts plutôt
positionnant on y va ce que je veux dire
c'est que l'italienne est plutôt un jeu
de pièces et l'écossaise plutôt un jeu
de pions voilà on va voir ça de 4,5
leucate début classique cavaliers trois
cavaliers c6 le coût habituel classique
on va défendre simplement le pire et là
on ouvre tout de suite avec le coût des
quatre voilà le coup qui caractérise
écossaise
alors voilà donc dans l'italienne le
choco piano on joue toujours ces trois
pour les d4 dans le l'espagnol on joue
aussi avec ces trois points des quatre
est là on dit on y va on ouvre les
lignes rapidement on omet le deuxième
pion au centre on construit notre centre
tout de suite
alors évidemment les droits doivent
prendre rendez catania pas il n'y a pas
de coup les autres coûts sont un peu
passif il faut casser le centre blanc
tout de suite tu aurais 44 et patron de
choix et cavaliers prend des quatre cas
les pans les cas voilà alors qu'est ce
qu'on a et bien on a un cavalier qui est
très bien placé au centre alors là il
faut que les noirs s'arrête de tout
échange est massivement puisque sur
cavaliers prend des cas très bien on
reprendrait avec adam et la dame serait
extrêmement bien placé au centre un
homme centralisée c'est tout ça fait
toujours très mal
alors oui la dame au centre c'est
toujours très bien son camp sauf contact
peut se faire attaquer par des pièces
noires qui se développe en même temps
ouais là il n'y a pas une pièce noire
qui peut se développer en même temps il
manque le carrément du cavalier b8 qui a
récompensé six elle peut se faire
attaquer par le penser mais le plan c
c'est pas une pièce et ça ça renforce
pas le contrôle du centre s'affaiblit
drôlement la casse des 5 1 voilà
s'affaiblit toute la colonne des en fait
depuis le 17 mai tenant et qui est un
petit peu à la traîne quand même
souffrir toute la partie voilà une belle
couleur rouge pour ses options faible
donc c'est pas bon du tout donc ça
serait pas une bonne solution alors en
fait ici les noirs ont deux possibilités
soit il joue cavalier f6 cariatides coup
logique voilà soit il joue fous ces 5
pouces et 5 po alors pour vous c'est
tout de suite
interrogé le cahier des quatre d'accord
voilà donc deux possibilités
qu'est-ce que j'ai choisi stéphane alors
regardez
la moins attendue à thouars tu vas voir
qu'elle est chose quand même
soc pointu c'est peut-être celle qui
bouge le plus dans une ligne en tout cas
on va voir alors alors gardent bon soit
on joue qu'un lycée 3 soit on prend ans
et 6 alors qu'alice et 3 on peut
peut-être un petit coup d'oeil voilà
qu'à et c3 alors là on a fouillé 4
évidemment qui est embêtant puisque le
cavalier est cloué avec une masse de
doublement des pions qui alors le
curieux 4 et emprise du combattant
voilà d'ailleurs on à la variante dans
notre parti un petit peu au dessus voilà
c'est ce qu'on voit la foulée 4 alors la
foulée 4 fait pression entre au calice
et trois qu'on veut protéger le pion à
eux quatre si on joue fou des trois qui
est le coup le plus normal pour poser le
public a très bien la dame perd le
contrôle sur les cavaliers des quatre sa
ferme cavani s'appellera cavaliers donc
on est obligé de se séparer d'abord du
canal les français 6 alors bien sûr on
reprend du plombier pas du pion d sinon
on est des rockets roi est très mal
placé au sens fort et apprendre à mieux
jouer simplement ajouté 2 foot et de
grock vois quelque chose de très
classique donc on prend du plomb au
courant du plan b et maintenant on peut
jouer au foot est roi d'après les deux
rocs petit recruter un petit rock et
bien et loire vont se servir de leurs
pions c6 qui a été ramené au centre pour
venir occuper le centre pour attaquer à
la casse des 5 pouces attaqué le pion à
voilà donc le clan rica a trait à
nouveau sous pression les blancs sont
séparés en faisant se prend des singes
alors c'est vrai qu'il des doubles les
pions les pions doublé et celle qui se
dit une bonne affaire pour lui noir
d'accord a priori a priori ce trailer
année le pion des hans et puis
maintenant ils se retrouveront dès 5 ans
voilà des noirs on sont encore les seuls
qui ont le pion ressemble donc c'est
effectivement ce qui peut paraître une
bonne affaire après fou g5
j'ai quand même voilà un petit problème
de clouage lecavalier f6 il occupait à
protéger le pion des 5
donc ça c'est un petit souci sedaka
menaces des plantes simplement se faire
fou prend 1,6 et là on serait bien
embêtée puisque si la dame reprenait un
rêve si c'est bien on perdrait tout
simplement le pian 2 des 5
ça ferait une fourchette en plus entre
la dame et le fougueux v4 qui
un peu dans le vide là donc voilà il
faut prendre des mesures défensives
urgente
donc c'est si c'est logique voilà je
consolide le central on a pu en d5 un
peu fragile et bien le consolide avec le
plan c est donc là bas effectivement
comme tu le disais c'est une variante
qui est sans grand danger pour les noirs
c'est pour ça que cavalier c3 n'est pas
le meilleur coup on va voir quel dédain
alternative mais voilà cette vente il
faut la connaître quand même là c'est
quand même bien pour les noirs pression
quand même un bon centre ici avec ses
six dessins voilà bon ceci dit ils sont
des pions quand même ces six dessins qui
sont la saga forme ils sont pendantes à
dire qu'ils sont un groupe de deux
isolés du reste des pions cela veut dire
qu'ils sont un peu sous pression il peut
être attaquée sans être défendue par
d'autres pions il ya une caste c5 qu'un
peu faible d'ailleurs le coup logique
ces cavaliers à 4 et 6 qui est rien bien
voilà pour essayer d'aller occuper la
classe c 5 à terme
voilà des choses comme ça
donc voilà ils veulent aussi poussé le
pion c'est donc pendant ces trois ans et
quatre pour essayer de casser ce duo de
pions et qu'il ne reste qu'un et que ce
pion soit isolé mais voilà donc sais
c'est un peu le plan des blancs qui ont
des petites idées mais on est d'accord
pour dire que c'est pas quand même un
gros problème pour les autres donc après
car les français 6 voilà donc en fait
qu'elle pense et si c'est le coût qui
est le plus dangereux car il sait 3-2
convient pas dans quel procès 6 alors là
eh bien on n'a pas trop le choix
on a fait faire des processus et
processus on ait des rookies on a encore
une fois des rockets avantage pour les
blancs et à présent on joue eux 5
voilà ce qui arrive souvent quand les
noirs n'ont pas encore stabilisé le
centre qui commencent à sortir les
cavaliers et bien on en profite en
continuant à l'avance des pions 4,5 et
là le cavalier
doit bouger à nouveau tôt ou tard alors
on est noir ont une petite astuce qui
n'est pas facile de comprendre au
premier abord c'est de jouer d'abord
dames cette dame c'est alors le pion ne
peuvent apprendre le cavalier évidemment
puisque la dame ferait échec aux moyens
conclut le pion l année noire créée un
clouage en bloquant un fouet fuite mais
il se trouve que la seule façon la seule
bonne façon pour les blancs de défendre
le pire de cinq bloqués c'est de jouer
dameuse
il faut jouer la mode il n'y a pas le
choix puisque tout autre pour les noirs
pour rejouer des six par exemple voilà
surtout aux deux par exemple alors
faisant perdre un pion aux 5e et sur f4
sur f 15 jours et décider sur fond et
voilà aujourd hui menace alors qu'on
compte gagner les noirs à intercaler
sékou dames cette dame de ça c'est une
question qui est intéressante et bien
les deux fous sont bloqués f8 et f1 donc
quand les foules sont bloqués on essaye
de les sortir par d'autres voies en
l'occurrence les chiens kétou donc un
fou sera rangée 737 et d'autres se
ranger deux voies la partie est le plus
fort entre le fou g7 et le fou g2 et
bien c'est fou j'ai sept puisque le fou
g7
il fait pression sur le pire de 5 et
quand même avancé et donc une cible
voilà donc c'est pour ça que les noirs
ont attaqué les le coup dams est il
pense que c'est à leur avantage et ils
ont sans doute raison mais là maintenant
tout de suite le carrier six salariés
le problème quand même
j'ai renouvelé le problème est
renouvelée sur le cavalier f6 il faut le
boucher du calife des 5 alors bah oui
parce que à chaque s'est en pris g4
aussi on veut pas rentrer à la maison
ensuite donc on joue en dessin qui reste
plus qu'une case et là il est encore
attaqué il a encore attaqué ses fans par
deux coups c4 c4 à l'ensemble comment la
dans la partie à liquide la partie
allait king ouais c'est un petit peu ça
le cavalier bouge on attaque on le
poursuit ou halal et noir un site fait
blanc à pousser leurs pions parce que
quand les pions s'avancer la position va
s'affaiblir inéluctablement donc on
incite à peu les pions blancs à être est
repoussée comme ça au centre alors là il
ya deux possibilités soit on joue à six
fois ci ça c'est marrant ça parce
qu'alors donc on avait déjà tout espions
c'est maintenant clos le pion c4 sur la
dame deux terrans toit plus prendre le
cavalier puisque la dame de serait
emprise donc c'est tendu puisque on
laisse une pièce emprise contrant
clouage donc cesser ces dépositions
exercices à réaliser effectivement
hélas le coût normal sur fois ci c'est
toujours une b3 métro simplon consolide
le pion v4 ou alors ces quatre ans alors
maintenant il faut que les noirs
s'organise
bon ils ont plusieurs coups pour
continuer leur activité ils ont soit le
coût g6 logique on va dire voilà soit le
coût g5 et n'est pas inintéressant
objets 6
ou alors j'ai cinq rien et même grand
roque est possible et encore une
possibilité grand roque voilà rock pour
éventuellement mettre la tour en jeu
tout de suite sur 8,8 et faire pression
maximale sur sur le pion aux scènes
toujours en visée ce pion voilà donc si
tu veux bien on va revenir la position
après b3 qui est une position des jeunes
est très intéressante et qui est cité
dans des manuels d'ouverture en fait
pour être un contre exemple des
principes d'ouverture
oui parce qu'on développe pas vite les
pièces avec les blancs on n'a rien
développé adams qu'il faut parce qu'il
faut pas faire c'est comme ça c'est
bizarre de l'autre côté les pièces
noires sont pas très bien développés
puisque le froid 6 ouais voilà c'est un
airways pourrait le cas et d5 et pas
forcément très bien passé en d5 d'éclat
dame va jouer la dame 2 il faudra
rebours jusqu'à mal à se rendre la
question c'est est-ce que le
développement noir l'état qu'un feu de
paille
c'est à dire une activité quand même
passagère et les blancs au sillon des
atouts qui peut faire valoir qui la
qualité de leurs structures de pions
puisqu'il n'y a pas un seul défaut dans
l'antre de plus grande car 5 est juste
un peu trop avancé peut-être mais n'est
pas faible et le pion le pion à 7 et
isoler les pions c'est son doublé il ya
trois îlots de pions contre deux pour
les blancs donc c'est ça l'idée de la
danse écossaise sait qu'on va avoir des
finales supérieur parce que les pions
sont un peu trop disloqué mal frotter
les mains on peut le dire
vous dites donc alors là et je suis
d'accord on regarde
alors j'ai six spots année aux 1,6 alors
que jean cys g6 alors là on va essayer
de concilier notre 2.5 puisque là
clairement les ambitions des noirs sont
affichés on veut s'en prendre plutôt 5
jouer fou voilà j'ai l'impression que ça
serait risqué alors par ailleurs
imaginons vous voilà alors non non non
et c6 alors voyons que jouer ou b2c tu
sais si tu veux si tu fais un coût
normal en tout cas normal c'est un coût
normal
le problème de fond b2c que en fait on
avait pour la protection des 5 et une
autre intention qui est de pousser les
pions f1 va jouer quatre alors là oui et
il nous faut c'est un il protège le pion
aux réflexions le voilà puisque salle
odyssée le carré des cinq c'est ce que
je voulais le noter sur fond d 2 c'est
que le cavalier des scènes peut protéger
la case f4 et attaquer la dame en même
temps plusieurs exact ce qui peut être
embêtant ce qui peut se recycler à
prendre 6 ce cavalier donc il sera mieux
placé quand des cinq ans gradins du
temps alors l'idée principale des blancs
dans cette position en fait de vite
enlever la dame 2e 2 / pour la mettre
sur le dos de gaz par exemple 4 il ya
d'autres cases possible pour que le pion
menace réellement le quartier des cinq
que le fourneau clouage du foie si sur
le plan ces cas ne soit plus effectif
donc on veut consolider très très vite
le pion à 5 pour ne plus être embêtés et
au coup suivant peut-être enlevé enlever
la dame en pouvoir attaquer donc f4
c'est un coup logique alors four b2 une
autre possibilité
alors pour ne pas laisser faire et bien
et noir peuvent jouer par exemple f6
pour essayer de faire sauter ce verrou
la pression ici sur le pion au sein
voilà c'est clairement le coup qui à mon
avis n'est le plus embêtant etienne
bacrot besoin d'un autre coup que f6 il
avait joué dame b 4 échecs à la place
des six donc si tu veux bien montré
l'assureur
mais quatre mois la nb4 on à la partie
dans la chic courant dans la base fou de
foot des deux voilà et d'un v6 voilà ça
c'était un coup joué par etienne bacrot
dans sa partie contre kasparov cancer à
niveau c'est ça qu'on va la chrétienne a
été invitée pour la première fois dans
un tournoi de très grandes catégories
l'an 2000 2001 en 2000 exactement et
voilà donc c'est une possibilité à une
spéciale des gones sur ce tournoi que
vous pouvez retrouver sombre on peut
retrouver dans 2004 et le cou blanc dam
leca et donc la balle à la partie
continue il va falloir tôt ou tard
bouger bouger le cavalier mais
maintenant le cavalier effectivement est
attaqué pour de vrai mais en mai 4 a
pris à trois il est perdu après il est
perdu c'est pour ça que les noirs ici
dans la partie et kasparov bas kroeff
5,5 seul coup pour déstabiliser
là ça devient un prêt va être très
compliqué c'est parti vous ça devient
très compliqué parce qu'après la
présente pas son aprf 5l après la
présentation est bien le roi
il vient en effet cet égard on
s'aperçoit que la torah 8 rentrer en jeu
sur une diagonale sur une colonne pardon
quand même un peu dangereuse
voilà donc c'est très chaud cetrel chose
il faut c'est faux le cavalier dans
l'air on va jouer simplement sans doute
au kung fu de webo boucher la colonne
gauche et la corée absolument et puis
après tony a laissé passer l'orage avec
le matériel que l'on a en plus et
l'arrosage de structures aussi voilà
donc sur f6 eh bien on a un coût comme
fou à 3 par exemple qui est un bon coup
fourré 3 aussi bien sûr qu'ils attaquent
ici la dame avec le produite en
transparence voilà la dame a d'abord f7
par exemple voilà et là on réalise notre
idée qui est de weedon des deux
sous-thèmes d2 avec toujours l'idée on
est sorti du clouage du fou c'est
toujours cette idée signaler tout à
l'heure pour alors quelle idée que
chercher à faire les blancs tout à
l'heure hélas le cavalier vraiment
attaquer et vous fasse cavalier n'a pas
de bonnes cases c'est pour ça que les
noirs ont été mal laisser au centre le
plus longtemps possible
oh ouais alors le plat ici d'un seul cas
ces cavaliers de beci ce qui présente un
inconvénient quand même c'est que à un
moment donné on va pouvoir jouer le coup
après l'échangé foot rasoir c4 c5 qui
crée une sorte d'étau sur l'option 17
ici là bon à la casse des 6 voilà tout
et tout et attaquer ici sur la caisse
des 6 et le pion 17 qui est un petit peu
à la traîne déception 17 qui va avoir
des voilà donc déjà on a quelques
quelques idées pour cette vente
écossaise avec des thèmes donc deux
bouts de reboucher la dame pour réitérer
la menace sur le cavalier et puis cette
idée c4 c5 aussi qui est possibilités
intéressantes pour pour exploiter
davantage de structures de pions qu'on a
bien alors ça c'est la variante avec
cavaliers f6 maternelle couche g6 où il
ya le coup g5y à peu près qu'il appelait
même idée à peu près la même idée au g5
augmente le contrôle sur les 4 voilà
donc un penseur jour f4 avec les blancs
voilà donc c'est pour ça qu'on joue j'ai
trois rouges et 3 voilà pour empêcher
cavaliers 4 voilà
et puis comme ça on pourra jouer tous
les deux le fougueux aussi fou g2 qui
est intéressant est fou j'ai de l'osi
bien sûr mais surtout g de kif a
commencé à faire pression sur une
diagonale où il ya un cavalier un pion
éventuellement ici mais a surtout la
torah 8
voilà bon très bien et puis le grand
roque haussier la passe de g5 qui est
une autre idée alors là pascal offrant
déjà pas trop g5 parce que ce sont des
élections très proche d'une voie bien
sûr de l'idée g6 grand roque avec l'idée
de mettre vite la tour en huit donc on g
3g 3 tridents l'idée très intéressante
pour les dents tours 8
pour 1,8 à alors attention puisque la
menace directe alors à la matin il ya
deux attaques sur le plus récent qu'on
défend avec fougue et 2g la f6 on a
l'impression que tout va s'effondrer que
le pion et 5 va tomber et bien oui il va
tomber et on s'en fiche on s'en fiche on
regarde bien je fous j'ai deux foulées 2
et surplus on prend 2,5
voilà on joue petit rock et en fait on à
combler notre retard de développement
et on ne va avoir une activité assez
intéressante sur le grand roque des
noirs qui est assez faible par exemple
dans la partie entre kasparov et karpov
dans le championnat du monde car pauvre
mais jouer à chaque juste la ceni point
une attelle posée
donc le matériel contenant on a rendu le
pion on a beaucoup d'activité et sûr dam
des deux ça va vite à mesdames d2
puisque j'ai envie on va pouvoir venir à
celle très vite
et voilà la pression sur le rsi sur le
pion à 7 avec le roi qui est derrière
attention tu as tout con ça va aller
très vite et surtout qu'on voit que la
structure des noirs ici quand même un
peu chaotique avec un gros trou sur la
case vaisselle après cavaliers m6 et
bien au jeu comme tu le disais dame à
5,6 un coût qui pique un peu après soit
on est très très embêté voilà alors
c'est une partie de rango posé ça va
être un peu fou d'ailleurs on pourrait
encore une fois retrouvé cette partie
kasparov karpov battu champion du monde
entre le lion d'or 90 sur le net on la
trouve facilement donc en référé moi
c'est de partir par an à vie dans toute
la partie là on donne les grandes idées
dans l'ouverture
voilà donc on a vu ses grandes idées sur
cavaliers m6 tf6 alors il ya une autre
idée où il se passe un peu moins de
choses c'est un peu plus positionnelle
c'est fou ces cinq coups qui paraît
quand même assez normal on développe le
fou et on met la pression sur le
cavalier des cadres à louis leca les
centrales alors c'est alors le plus haut
qui prend ses six volontairement on a
fait l'impasse sur le coup fou ou 3
parce que c'est une bande très très
compliqué avec les blancs nous on nous
conseille de jouer
sable des cahiers français s'ils vont
jouer simple la structure direct
cavaliers processes unis décès de civils
noirs prennent évidemment la casse et la
structure de pions qui va être un atout
en finale voilà si on reprend donc on va
avancer alors il ya le coup parce que
s'ils ont ce qu'on veut faire en fait
c'est dépenser 6 pour avoir des lignes
ouvertes pour nos tours colonnes le
aider si on vous voit là si on prend
si on prend tout de suite et a toujours
un inconvénient c'est qu'on va dire ok
donc c'est pas être aisée rossi aura
quasiment finale avec une structure de
plus en faire une structure depuis en
très mauvaise et puis le roi au centre
de la place à beaucoup un petit coup
intermédiaire une sorte de menace de
maths du berger avec les lois alors si
un mode du berger à l'envers puisque la
la menace pour les noirs c'est bien le
match du berger avec tu apprends f2
protégé par le foot c'est simple et
échec et mat puisque le roi n'a plus de
possibilité de s'échapper par toutes les
cases sont contrôlés par la dame donc
serait il saurait bien matt notre roi
blanc
voilà donc c'est la mena donc il faut
parer cette menace pour elle une façon
la plus simple et la plus élégante dame
des deux dames des deux à la fois
alors pourquoi de me desbiens plutôt aux
dames le 2 bat en fait on a une double
idée qu on verra plus tard peut-être
c'est que la dame elle peut bondir en f4
à plus tard elle peut bondir en escale
voilà elle peut dire la f4 pour proposer
un échange de dames et pour faire valoir
la meilleure structure des blancs voilà
alors que sur dame de la da est en fait
c'est bon on a un problème sur f2 donc
nous résoudrons le rauque et les
policiers il faut sortir le fouet f1
voilà donc belle âme attend les noirs
doivent reprendre ses 6 alors si on peut
reprendre avec b mais c'est pas très
logique puisque le fou demande qu'à
sortir il y est donc
on peut reprendre avec la dame pour la
structure de pions ça c'est un coup que
peut-être les débutants pense que c'est
meilleur que c'est meilleur que les
autres
mais la dame n'est pas bien placée du
tour ces six ans joue cavalier c3 par
exemple et on s'aperçoit qu'on pourra
pas bouger le pion déjà on va jouer des
six à cause de l'ignoble fou est simple
la montre est quand même des 6 es fou
des cinq ans regardez c'est horrible
puisque la dame c6 et cloud est
impossible de bouger à cause de ce
superbe foulée celle qui gagne à dame
voilà un coup classique donc
donc il faut éviter de faire de faire
d'un processus qui est paquet paniquez
pas idéal quoi voilà c'est pas du tout
il est donc on fait des processus donc
on fait des processus voilà donc on va
continuer avec qu'américains et ses 3 on
se développe on protège le pian
développe on se développe
voilà un an il ya plusieurs possibilités
il ya soit fou et 6 soit cavaliers de
cette soif ou des quatre peut-être
regarder cavaliers sept cavaliers cette
année clariant a priori le plus logique
pour parvenir aux eurocks elle a
maintenant que le cavalier de recettes
ne contrôle plus la table si c'est bien
la jouer d'un f4 f4 voilà la tension il
ne peut pas les noirs permettre
d'apprendre avec la structure qui se
cassent de l'autre côté aussi ça fera
deux structures cas c'est donc la mef 4
alors on va voir quand même que c'est
une petite idée d'abord il faut
s'arrêter sur la structure de pions on
va regarder cette position sans les
pièces juste avec les pions et on a une
structure qui est bien connue où on a
des pions e f g h pour les blancs là
c'est la majorité des noirs que tu
montes voilà et avons montré la majorité
des blancs en verre maintenant contre e
f g h
voilà et ça ça fait des pions passer ça
fait un pion passé on a un pion au
candidat qui apparaît sur ce plan qui en
plus avec leur faim qui pourra être en
plus à la fin voilà alors que la
majorité des noirs elle s'est abaissée
cet essai 6 entre abc et le défaut de
structure des noirs à savoir les plans
doublé ne leur permet pas de créer un
pion passé
c'est pour ça que systématiquement les
les blancs recherche une finale
voilà il essaye en fait les change de
pièce ne les dérange pas donc des dames
encore moins et damien 4 est un coût qui
non seulement a taxé 7 en plus proposer
les chances de dames
alors c'est vrai que si on prenait en f4
se développerait le fou oui si on sait
aussi un inconvénient sur sa développe
le fou c'est un avis gain de temps et en
plus son latin plus qu'ils ont c'est
cette voie là on est obligé de retard de
vingt ans pourquoi pour le protéger
ainsi donc alors les noirs pour jouer
ici un coup un peu étrange il montre que
régis voilà ils laissent prendre
il est doublé les pions alors c'est vrai
ça fera une belle dame un peu pour y ait
le droit à un peu pourri mais il laisse
prendre parce qu'ils ont quand même un
coût plus tard qui va lui permet de se
libérer c'est le coup f6 f5 au moins
pour dédoubler les pions alors voilà
dame précise puis on va voir ce que
libérateur à 6 7 5
protégé par fo s'est vite qui va selick
tôt ou tard loin 24 et on voit quand
même que la structure noir ça fait bien
encore plus affaiblie mais ils ont un
congé ouverte ils ont un jeu de pièces
intéressant alors échangé à du jeu pour
les pièces on a beaucoup de parties de
très haut niveau se sont orientés
notamment encore une fois une partie de
kasparov contre topalov 3 de las palmas
bon il ya très longtemps croisé le jeune
topalov n'était pas aussi fort que
maintenant les choisit de rentes
inférieures il choisit une vente
inférieur et d'ailleurs il avait tenu là
nul dans cette position contre le grand
kasparov
c'est chaud voilà alors cavaliers hausse
est une possibilité on a également
d'autres coup quand en fout des quatre
on met une pression sur le cavalier c3
on a aussi une autre idée qu'est de
boucher la colonne des laon couple
actions de la dame sur la classe des
huit couples action donc on va pouvoir
faire le grand roque exactement on va
pouvoir ramener la tour en des huit en
faisant le grand roque en mettant le roi
à l'abri donc c'est un coût qui est très
intéressant sur alors fou des trois
cavaliers c'est encore une fois cette
manoeuvre petit rock héroïque et coûts
sont simples cavaliers g6
on essaye d'aller chatouiller un peu les
caisses noires cavaliers aux deux que le
cavaliere se tiennent en f4 à noter
qu'on ne pouvait pas soi même joué
quatre corps était un bon coup à cause
du fou qui fait évidemment claudio 12
faut quand même noter que ça donne un
pion en b2 mais que si les noirs ou en
chercher un fou prend b2 toujours se
méfier des pions en faisant des essais
des pions qu'on va chercher mais qui en
fait nous coûte du temps développement
donc flambé dont le 1er 2 et bien on
peut jouer par exemple le coût f4 ide 5
et f5 avec son grosse grosse attaque sur
le roi noir ici aussi
voilà c'est toujours un peu délicat
d'aller chercher les pions comme ça tant
que tout le fou c'est 8 peut pas trop
partir ce que les pions baissait très
perdu après tomber un manuel sur le deck
le football on va chercher le cube et 7
avec une structure noirs ici
complètement disloqué voilà donc ça
serait problématique d'aller chercher
sur donc sur sur cavaliers aux yeux bien
on fourbit 6 tout simplement car lieu de
donc on joue le coup simple ou à la
décision va pas chercher le pion
empoisonné les deux le foot ici ce qui
empêche l cas toujours avec cette idée
que le fou il cloue look le pion est
mené on peut pas jouer 4 qui sera mon
continent voilà cavaliers g3 rendre à
s'arrêter là peut-être parce que on a
déjà quand même pas mal d'éléments de
développement alors l'idée pour les
blancs effectivement ces rois achats
suivis de f4 voilà qui est logique à
cette position parce qu'on contrôle
dreux et 4 avec food à mes tours et puis
on may fc quand même la majorité qu'on
met en branle contre contre voilà
serais-tu noter tout à l'heure où
l'iphone mathis il faut mettre en joue
et la majorité face à cette minorité ici
là voilà quatre pions qu'on 3 c'est
toujours un critère pour avancer ses
pions voilà c'est ainsi davantage blancs
les noirs ont une position qui est pas
si mauvaise que ça puisque toutes leurs
pièces vont se développer quand même
relativement facilement ils ont ouvert
le jeu grâce à ce surcoût des princesses
voilà ce que claire processes voilà
c'est tout l'enjeu de la position c on a
une nouvelle structure mais on a quand
même des lignes nouvelles
on touche deux pièces c'est
effectivement donc on avait sept fous
vous n'avez qu'un des quatre portant des
fouos 6 aussi et nous devrions nous on
va voir que les thèmes sont à peu près
les mêmes alors tak tak haute voix la
foux aussi s'apprête à laisser 3 la
troisième coup possible faut 6 x 6 voilà
donc là les blancs on va les blancs ils
ont encore pas mal de coups à leur
disposition mais il ya ce coup de
kasparov contre youssou peuvent être
très intéressant ces cavaliers à 4
cavalcade
j'attaque ici le c5
tout simplement pour des huit joué par
hugh pope dans un parti célèbre tombe
les huit attaques gagnantes en attaquant
un cadre à son intermédiaire la food & 3
ans donc on va se développer en parents
un peu cette attaque deux tours sur la
dame dessous des 4 as il faut que vous
quand même bouger le fou fou des quatre
voilà voilà petit rock et mis des
couleurs ou des cartes huawei même temps
on a libéré la dame de la défense du
pion f2 et sur un coup comme à 6 on a un
coût qui est très surprenant mais que
thématique dans la partie écossaise et
d'un bassin
oui on l'a déjà vu tout à l'heure sur le
grand roque oui évidemment voilà sauf
que là mais il ya encore l'intérieur qui
met à chatouiller le pion s'assèche à
tous les fiancés 7 avait l'idée qu'on
foule et si c'est pas possible à cause
tout simplement de cavalli prend voilà
dont vie du fait que le cavaliere 4
empêche ou v6 pour les attaques et on
sait c est un peu comme b6 est
sanctionné par la perte du coup on
assiste voilà donc il ya déjà des gros
gros problème pour les noirs sur la dame
mais il ya quand même du contre eux je
sais sur le pion à f2 avec un coût par
exemple comme cavalier à schiste
cavaliers gkd donc on va regarder damas
cinq baies 5 baies 5 contre attaque
le cavalier à 4 jusqu'avec a blessé
trois par exemple on se fout b6
maintenant faible et si c'est possible
ben oui parce qu'on dit a dû vous le
pire on vient prendre le pion voilà même
étonnamment à six radars ainsi donc la
contrepartie d'un pont pour les noirs en
l'occurrence yusupov ici dans sa partie
bankass parole c'est qu'il a
effectivement perdu aussi mais il a
isolé la dame la dame
voilà c'est quand même des compensations
assez intéressante puisque la dame est
encore à venir allait aller bloquer à
tout de suite prête à rejouer et donc
c'est de ce côté-là que voilà les noirs
on dire maintenant que la dame est
coupée il manque un grand défenseur
voilà il va y avoir du cavalier hachey
ce qui arrive donc il va la voir
et c'est pas inintéressant puisqu'il va
y avoir une attaque sur le petit rock
alors que les blancs pour pouvoir
éventuellement cabaye âge si
éventuellement par et avec un coup comme
fou et 3 ou bien h3 peut-être même si
h3c affaiblissant en tout cas pour le
pion ça va coûter peut-être aux blancs
de passer un mauvais quart d'heure
voilà mais c'est quand même une idée
pour gagner du matériel c'est une idée
qui est très intéressante et avait gagné
la partie c'est toujours le fameux
équilibre
on peut prendre le matériel souvent en
échange dit me satisfont adversaire
était sacré dit qu'il y avait 100 ou de
la ville et que c'est une partie plutôt
positionnelle pragmatique il ya un pion
à prendre on le prend et sont les noirs
qui recherche ont au contraire des
compensations dynamique
donc effectivement c'est un thème un
petit peu différent d'eux
de toutes ces parties comme l'italienne
où il ya tech sur fc ya beaucoup de
beaucoup de vies là c'est respect de la
structure de pions j'ai envie de jouer
une finale parce que ma finale est
supérieur et j'ai un jeu assez
pragmatique voilà ce que je suis content
je joue l'écossaise voilà on a vu les
deux grandes lignes de l'écossaise
évidemment il ya beaucoup de petites
souligner mais en tout cas là on a un
bagage assez intéressant pour pouvoir
commencer des parties sur l'écossaise
qui coince et comprendre ses idées voilà
le plus important de comprendre que
d'apprendre toutes les petites suit on
en oublie au fur et à mesure de toutes
façons voilà donc c'est la fin de cette
leçon express donc écossaise merci aux
journalistes
merci stéphane à bientôt morvan